after months of stalemate things are
starting to happen in this war Alex
Rossi reported for on the new phase of
this battle for back but concentrating
in the South where the ukrainians are
pushing hard to keep the access road
open and like in all battles it feels
pretty complicated and dangerous to
those on the ground and further north
the ukrainians have also been making
some inroads against Russian positions
and for the Russians the fear must be
that they could be encircled behind back
much if they don't rush some reserves
both to North and to South to prevent it
but of course this is only one small
section of a Battlefront that is
potentially over 600 miles long now we
don't know where the main Ukrainian
punch may come but the Russians clearly
think that it might come in the South
because they're building some very big
defenses shown here in red they
obviously think that they've got
something really important to defend in
that southern area
any Ukrainian offensive is only possible
with the help of the West and the latest
figures up to the end of February show
over 75 billion pounds worth of Aid has
been committed 75 billion and the UK has
given the second most of that total so
there's a lot of it but it's all coming
stages now and again dribs and drabs are
some say it which is less than ideal
the UK has taken a very positive
attitude but just look at the number of
individual announcements that we have
made in the 14 months since the War
Began there were only four months where
we didn't make one announcement often
two and in one case even four
announcements all in one month and these
announcements were all separate
announcements of discrete packages of
military aid that we intended to give
and the point the ukrainians keep making
is if the Western only committed earlier
and more clearly what they were prepared
to do then they the ukrainians would now
be in a very different position
however we are where we are
we think that the ukrainians have around
12 maybe up to 16 brigades of infantry
mechanized infantry and most importantly
armor brigades and the way these
elements work together and are used by
Ukraine will be the key in the coming
months to their success or lack of it
and for all of this the Ukraine is still
say they need Western Jets
they feel that that air superiority and
they're not wrong about this will decide
who will win in any given battle space
now some Western politicians think that
zielinski is actually crying wolf over
the f-16s
I guess we'll find out pretty soon
whether he is or not